What's up guys welcome to episode 2 of ICT for Dummies. This is gonna be a psychology episode. Please watch this video all the way through
It's really important
The topic for today is gonna be surrender your ego if you think that you don't need to watch this video because you're better
Or smarter than other people
I'll have you know that
Psychology is one of the most important things on the planet and you are no better than anyone else watching this video guys want to
Become better traders and better people so watch this shit all the way through don't think that you're at an advantage when you start
Something everyone starts off with not knowing anything and everyone needs to put their head down lock in if they want to learn something
Don't think that there's shortcuts to things in life
Don't think that not trying is cool people who give a fuck actually care to learn and enjoy the process are those who see
Results I've heard it from people before like hey, can you teach me how to trade?
I bet you I can learn faster than other people I can learn in two weeks. It doesn't seem hard at all
I learn other things fast like you're not special when it comes to trading. I'm gonna tell you straight up
Psychology is undeniably one of the most important factors if not the most important factor of all of trading
But you cannot have a good psychology if you don't work day in and day out
On and off the charts to make yourself a better person guys to make any sort of progression in your life
You must surrender your ego. You cannot do the same thing every single day and then magically expect a different result guys
I want you to know that we've been in your exact shoes and what I'm gonna be telling you guys
We're gonna give you homework, right? For example, we're gonna tell you soon to start back testing
We're gonna tell you soon start journaling and we're gonna tell you these things
Because we've been there because we know that these are the steps that we need to be taken to become profitable
You need to completely be vulnerable with yourself and let us help you
We've seen it a million times before where someone will pass their first account start making money and the second they see a bit of results
They stop practicing all the fucking good habits they had when they actually wanted it. You got to remember that feeling
24-7 you got to put your head down and treat it just like when you started even when you're making money
Like I've said it we've seen it so many times. They'll get their first payout. They'll stop journaling
They'll stop doing the technical analysis
They need to they'll start waking up one minute before market opens and think that they know everything and that they can take trades half
awake
Listen, everyone has a different journey
Everyone has different timing but everyone who sees success does the same thing
They put their head down every single day and they treat it like it's the first and a guy guys you need to be taking
Accountability for every single thing that happens. You cannot blame it on the market
You cannot blame it on any other factor other than yourself because at the end of the day you are the person that is pushing
The button you are the person that is making the same mistakes over and over again
And again, you are not going to see any sort of progression if you're just making the same mistakes and you're not writing it down
You're not journaling them the better you understand your emotions the better
You're gonna be able to manage them become in tune with yourself talk with yourself journal in the morning
How you feel before you trade make sure you're level-headed after you trade journal the trade
These are good habits you need to practice every day make your fucking bed
Do the little things build that discipline become an actual good person and it's gonna equate to you being a good trader
When you start trading you are going to be taking bad trades. It's inevitable
It's going to happen
But what you have to do after taking those bad trades is journal it you have to write down your confluences
Write down your emotions. How are you feeling before your trade?
How are you feeling after your trade and that is how you are going to progress the fastest the people that don't progress are the
People that make those mistakes and then you know, they forget about it. They don't journal it
They don't do anything
How the fuck do you think you're gonna see any sort of progress if you're not journaling if you're not surrendering your ego if you're
Not being vulnerable with yourself
And then there's people who make progress and then take a hundred steps backwards because they got comfortable
Don't become comfortable
Listen, you guys are all watching this video because you share the same purpose
You want to become profitable you want to live out your dream life and I'll have you know that the market does not give a fuck
About you. It doesn't care if you got straight A's in high school
It doesn't care if you've gotten all the girls in the world
It doesn't give a fuck if you're the biggest person at the gym
You're still not a good trader until you can put your head down like the rest of everyone else who has seen success in
The markets and to save you some time in your journey to profitability if you don't want to take this seriously and you think you're
The shit just wait till one day you get so sick of breaking your rules because you couldn't practice any good habits
That you're either gonna quit or you're gonna have to actually start giving a fuck and learning everything that you need to
There are no shortcuts in life surrender your ego guys